Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
Okay. We're picking back up again.
And with a Spider-Man,
which is the conclusion of the story where Peter Parker meets miles Morales for
the very, very first time, right?
Peter Parker from the main level universe meets the ultimate Spider-Man miles
Morales.
And the whole idea behind this is that we pick up with Peter Parker following
his kind of encounter alongside, uh,
miles with Mysterio who used basically use the kind of robot version of himself
to move into the ultimate universe or to travel to the ultimate universe. Uh,
Peter Parker is essentially traveled to meet, uh,
the ultimate universes version of Gwen Stacy and Mary Jane Watson.
Now keep in mind the last time they saw Spider-Man,
it was their version of Peter Parker and he died in largely,
there was just kind of the grieving process that went into it. Now,
one of the things that we talked about in the early miles Morales comics that we
did is that there did come a point when miles took on the vitamin in costume and
was met by aunt Mae and Gwen Stacey. And they were kind of like, look,
if you're going to do this,
understand that you're living up to a legacy much bigger than yourself, right?
You don't just simply put on the Spider-Man costume and do your thing.
You're living up to the legacy that my nephew created. Uh,
and you stand for everything he stood for.
So this is not a thing to take lightly, right?
So it was kind of initially they were against it, but it's one of these things.
We're just kind of like, okay, you know,
we can sort of get on board once they realize the character of miles Morales and
what he had to offer. But the problem with this is that when Peter shows up,
he's wearing the original Spider-Man costume. And as soon as aunt Mae sees this,
she gets, right?
Because he basically showed his face and her thought is as some kind of a,
some kind of a joke, right?
When Stacy shows up and starts kicking the crap out of a, at a Peter Parker,
thinking the heat, pulling a stunt to,
and it's not until miles shows up and says, no, no, no, no, no, no.
It's really actually Peter, right? It's not somebody pulling it up,
pulling a trick or something like that. And not somebody being a jerk,
I don't really know of a reasonable human being that would show up on the
doorstep of a woman.
And like basically two chicks who lost somebody close to them,
dressed as that person. Right. I mean, if somebody were to do that,
I would wholly, like I would stand by and just watch them,
get the crap kicked out of them. I'd record it. And then just be like, yeah,
man, this guy kind of had a coming like Debbie, my response I'd be like, yeah,
man, like they were kind of a Dick. They sort of had this coming. Right.
Nobody do anything. Let them get their just desserts. But, uh,
this is actually Peter, right? This is actually Peter Parker here.
And when miles comes to his rescue, that's when aunt may end up Gwen,
Stacy basically start to listen. Right. And Peter's initial responses like,
like I thought initially I died. I thought something happened. Like,
I didn't really know what was going on, how I ended up here. You know,
I've only recently been putting the pieces together.
I never should have come here, but I never should have come here to this place.
You know, I'm sorry I did this to you.
And then basically aunt may passes out right now. At that point,
we switch over to the ultimate universe, Tony stark and Nick fury right now,
Nick fury we've talked about before ultimate universe Ironman.
We've never really had a big discussion about one of the big things to
understand here is that ultimate iron man when he first showed up was designed
to be a more grounded version of Tony stark from the main Wilder universe.
Right? So not as intelligent because even Tony in the main Marvel universe,
his intelligence, even for the realm of comics borderlines questionable, right?
Like how could a person possibly be that smart?
This version of Tony is really smart,
but he is a version of intelligence we would expect to see here in the real
world, right?
Hence the nature of the ultimate universe kind of reflection of the real world,
the way it exists now.
And so he's not really able to pick up or really figure out what Mysterio of
what's what's going on with mysterious character, right?
How to reverse engineer, the circuitry, where the signals coming from, any,
all that kind of stuff.
The reality of this is there's an infinite number of universe is out there,
right?
And Tony just doesn't have the ability to trace a signal back to its origin
point. Now, if this were in the main Marvel universe, the main Marvel,
Tony stark would have figured it out like that, right.
He would've figured it out so fast because it's what the story called for it.
But the idea of the ultimate universe was to write more realistic stories,
right? And really, if you're talking about an infinite number of universes,
there really wouldn't be a way to trace the signal all the way back to its
origin point,
because it's not like it's a rope that leaves from the main mobile universe.
And all they have to do is just follow the breadcrumbs to get to its location.
It doesn't really work that way, at least not for anybody here.
And so at the end of the day, Tony doesn't really have any answers here.
He's like the only way for me to really get some answers is to talk to that
alternate reality version of Spider-Man to talk to Peter Parker is the only way
for me to really figure out what it is that's going on here. Now,
the funny comment he makes is I'm surprised that you let miles Morales run
around with Peter Parker. And I figured you would attract them over the head,
throw them into a hole, uh, and, and basically grabbed like the,
the main Peter and done the same thing, right? Kind of, you know,
kept miles Morales under wraps so that he wouldn't really have any idea what's
going on. And then basically took Peter and, and just kind of locked him up.
But the idea behind this is that fury really feels a bit of regret when it
comes to Peter, right? Peter was never properly trained to become a superhero.
He was never properly trained.
He wasn't really inducted the way that he was supposed to be.
He was just kind of allowed to do his thing. And that led to his eventual death.
And Nick fury felt a lot of responsibility for that.
That's why when you go and you read cataclysm,
but there's a lot of focus put on Nick fury and the guilt.
He feels for the death of Peter Parker because when he could have trained him or
he could have helped him to become a better hero, he didn't instead,
it was just kind of him doing his thing. And so with that guilt in mind,
along with promises that he made, it's kind of like,
we're just going to let them work it out together. Right.
Which is actually the right move.
The best move for Nick fury to make is really for Peter on Meg when Stacy to all
kind of come to terms with this on their own. And so once our may wakes up,
you basically have Peter like telling stories, you know, two,
two miles into Gwen, Stacy, them sharing stories with him, that kind of a thing,
and kind of going back and forth right in Peter's coming to this realization.
There's massive differences between this reality and the one that he's from now,
we, as the reader know that one of the funny things that goes on is Gwen,
Stacy kind of starts poking and prodding and is like,
is there a version of me in your universe? And Peter's like, yeah,
but she's a little bit older than you are. You know, she's about my age.
And she's like, well, I mean, you know, like, are you dating her?
And Peter's like, I mean, not really, like, I'm,
I'm basically dating Mary Jane Watson. Right. Which is what, when Stacy calls.
And then as soon as,
as soon as this kind of explanation goes on that Mary Jane is like a supermodel
where she's not in the ultimate universe where she's just like a nerdy girl when
it's like, she's a supermodel and all that kind of stuff. Like Wednesdays,
he's kind of shocked to find out that like Mary Jane Watson is this hugely
popular world renowned model. And it's kind of like, wow, that's a little crazy.
But when she starts asking, uh, what about me? Right? Like, what am I then?
Like, what's going on with me? Peter's like, wait, we should,
we should probably talk about something else.
I don't have the heart to tell you that the green goblin threw you off a bridge.
And I shot my at my wedding at your foot and broke your neck in the process
because I was basically what happened. I don't care what anybody says.
She was not dead.
Before vitamin got there. I don't care what anybody says, but.
Uh, you know, it's, it's, it's kind of an interesting thing because it's like,
there are parts of his reality.
He doesn't really want to divulge because who knows how Gwen Stacy would react.
If it was like, well, you're dead.
And I'm the reason why then it's kind of like get out of this house. Right.
You know, I don't want you here,
but it's really kind of new to her to learn a really fascinating for her to
learn that there's whole other world and dimensions out there now for her part,
aunt may is a lot more reserved here.
Why she's not nearly as excited as Gwen Stacy is, you know,
she's kind of braking,
bracing herself with the idea that it's not actually Peter Parker.
They're just like, well, we don't really know if it's Peter Parker.
We don't really know if it's him. Right. We don't know if that's the case.
It could be somebody else pretending to be him now. And in fact,
like it really is him. We know that miles Morales believes that Gwen,
Stacy believes that, but aunt Mae's doing this because in her heart of hearts,
if she gives into this and then it turns out to be false, she'd lose it. Right?
Like it would just be the most crushing experience because for her,
when she kind of asked Peter, you know, what led you to be at, to,
to become this person, right?
When he kind of starts talking to her about like uncle Ben, uncle,
Ben's the reason why he does this,
that uncle Ben of course is dead and his reality. But the fact that,
that he could have saved uncle Ben and he didn't is the reason why he became a
superhero, the way that he did and the idea that he could,
he could basically help other people. And in a lot of ways,
a tone for his past mistake,
he basically runs off the statement with great power. And then she finishes.
It comes great responsibility. Now it should be must come. Great responsibility.
The fact that this is a lesson that Peter was taught by uncle Ben tells,
automate everything. She needs to know that it really is him.
And that's where she kind of gives herself over incest. We thought like,
we lost you. Right. We lost you. And we didn't even get to say goodbye.
And that's the important thing here. Right?
That's the important thing to understand.
That's why aunt Mae kept herself reserved in this part. Right.
Because if she had said like, okay, yeah,
you're probably Peter and let her whole self believe it.
And then it turned out to just be some alternate reality version of Peter who
was evil or something like that. But it wasn't like the,
this alternate reality counterpart to the one that she knew what,
just to say a good guy who fights the good fight and does what heroes do then it
would have broken her in her entirety, right? Like the, the,
the inability of her to say goodbye,
the chances she had did the fact that she never got to tell here that she was
proud of him, that she loved him, but to never say, never be able to say,
I'm sorry, or any of that stuff, right. To basically like confessor or to,
to kind of get to say her last goodbyes to him is something that's always
haunted her having Peter here, this alternate reality version of Peter,
even though she knows us, not her actual nephew,
she knows is not the Peter Parker from the ultimate universe,
gives her a chance to effectively say goodbye, right. To say her goodbyes and,
and, you know,
indirectly say it to Peter Parker from ultimate universe to give her closure is
basically what this does. Something that she's never had this entire time.
And so Mazda, Miralis looking out the window realizes, ah, okay,
shields on their way we need to go. Right? Because shield is a lot more seedy.
And the ultimate universal, they are in the main Marvel universe,
the main Marvel universe, they're still kind of jerks, but like,
they're more inclined to work with you than against you and the ultimate
universe. They're like a, like a, like a police force almost. Right. I mean,
not specifically, but in terms of like how they function, right?
Like they do their thing. And all,
there are just people who stand in the way is basically all that it is.
But of course, Peter ends up saying goodbye to, uh, to everybody here.
And then of course he ends up getting in the car with, uh,
Nick fury miles Morales.
And it's kind of a funny thing because Nick fury asks like,
is there a Nick fury where you come from? And he's like, yeah,
but he's kind of a white guy. And then like, Nick fury is like,
sorry to hear that, man. We're just kind of a funny thing. But again,
it gives me the closure she needs. And that's why when the story came out,
it was so huge.
It was wrapping up all these plot threats by all these little things that have
been left hanging. And the reality is that if anybody, but Brian,
Michael Bendis had taken this over, we probably would have never seen this.
Right. The Bendis started off with a, with the ultimate Spiderman.
He originally created it.
It makes sense that he would basically end it here and kind of continue things
on with miles. And that's why Spider-Man is so important.
It's one part wrapping up plot threads that Bendis never got to wrap up after
the death of Peter Parker and the ultimate universe and the cataclysm story.
And it was a way to kind of officially transition into the miles and we'll find
more, find out more why that's the case when we get,
once we get to the end of this. But when he, when he really meets with,
you know, Tony star, he's coming, okay. So there's a few differences here.
Like one, the Tony stark in my universe stopped drinking a while ago,
which Nick fury loves. And too, it's obvious this guy is not as smart.
And so with, with Tony kind of being like, look like,
I need to know where his home is. I need to know where your universe is. Uh,
when Peter starts to point them in that direction, then it turns into, okay,
then we can, at the very least figure out how to get you back. Right.
We can figure, you know, we can figure out how to reverse engineer this stuff.
Now make no mistake.
Tony starts not doing this out of the goodness of his heart.
Tony starts doing this one part because he was directed by Nick fury, but two,
because he can get something out of it, right? I mean, this is, uh,
a level of technology that Tony just doesn't have access to being able to attain
this technology and use it for his own ends. It's a huge benefit, right?
It's something that he desperately wants here. And so once,
once they're basically looking at the broadcast that Mr has been putting out,
you know, over the internet, you know, all day long.
And for how many days he's been here,
miles picks up on the fact that one of these buildings is actually in Brooklyn,
right? He's like one of these villages in Brooklyn, I'm familiar with it.
And so they know exactly where it is Mysterio is operating out of,
or they know his base of operations.
Once they locate that Nick fury calls in everyone. And when I say everyone,
I mean an entire shield strike team alongside Spiderman and alongside the
ultimate four. But with that being said, guys,
free to bring this video to an end. If you are new here to comments,
explain to make sure you guys at the sub button to become part of the Rob core.
If you guys enjoyed this video, make sure you drop a like.
No, we'll catch you all later, Bruce.